hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about when not to use bacteriostatic
drugs so just to review really quickly
there are two major categories of drugs
with in respect to treating bacterial
infections there are drugs that are
bacteriostatic meaning that they prevent
the multiplication the growth of the
bacteria in the patient and that's
represented here by bacteria that have
been lassoed that have rope tied around
them to keep them from going anywhere
keep them from doing anything mainly
keep them from from replicating the
other major class of antibiotic is
called bactericidal so that is when the
bacteria are actually killed by the drug
so these are dead bacteria so now with
that in mind there are times when a
bactericidal drug that actually kills
the bacteria is essential for a good
outcome in a patient so for example when
the patient's own immune system can't
kill bacteria very well such as in cases
of immunodeficiency so think about maybe
people who are HIV positive of a
suppressed immune system people who are
undergoing radiation treatments and
chemotherapy for cancer that have had
their immune system weakened by that the
elderly the very young people who are
that have some kind of immune system
disease think like severe combined
immunodeficiency syndrome things like
that
these are all examples of
immunodeficiency when a patient's own
immune system just can't take care of
the bacteria by themselves so impact
Iria static drug that just prevents the
most location and rates for the immune
system to kick in that's not going to
help these people and so a bactericidal
drug is really critical in that case and
a bacteriostatic drug would not be
effective there's also cases when a
patient would die or have major brain
damage before a bacteriostatic drug can
be effective so basically if the
infection is too severe or or think
about things like encephalitis also
meningitis cases of sepsis these are all
very very serious types of infections
where a bacteriostatic drug just can't
be effective quickly enough to save the
patient's life and so that's why the
bacteria's bactericidal drug would be
required in those cases another type of
case or you really need one of these
bactericidal drugs it actually kills the
bacteria itself is when the site of
infection is poorly accessible to the
immune system so when cells of the
immune system like phagocytic cells
cannot access the site of infection so
for example endocarditis when you have
an infection of heart valves this is
another that this is an example of when
you have an infection in a place where
the immune system just can't get to it
and with a bacteriostatic drugs just
prevent multiplication for a while in
order to let the immune system take care
of the infection but if the immune
system cells can't get there then once
the patient stops taking the bacterias
out of drugs the infection is going to
continue and put it at full strength so
that's why again this bactericidal drug
is really important in a case like this
so you might be asking yourself well
when would you want to use these
bacteriostatic drugs well there are
certain bacterias that drugs that target
very specific bacteria
so if your doctor can diagnose you with
a very specific pathogen sometimes there
are bacteriostatic drugs that are
designed for that pathogen in particular
that would be a good thing to take also
it's possible that sometimes it may be
the only drug available due to
antibiotic resistance and that's pretty
scary antibiotic resistance is a really
problem is getting bigger and bigger
over time where fewer and fewer of our
drugs are working against various
bacterial pathogens because so many of
them have become resistant and so if a
bacteria and the bacteria aside drug is
the only one that's going to work then
that's just all there is and you have to
hope that the patient's immune system is
going to be effective enough to take
those bacteria that are being held in
check by the bacteria side drug and
actually kill them another example is
when it's used in conjunction with
another drug for synergistic effects and
what this means is that sometimes you
can have two bacteriostatic drugs that
are bacteriostatic when they're applied
separately but when they're applied
together they're actually bactericidal
so that's an example of when you can use
two drugs at the same time to treat the
same infection and get a more powerful
effect and a better outcome so that's
another time when bacteriostatic drugs
might be used if you want a more
in-depth explanation of the differences
between bacteriostatic and bactericidal
then please check out my video on
bacteriostatic versus bactericidal drugs
and if you want to learn a bit more
about the antibiotic resistance problems
that we are encountering as a human
population in our in our
sort of medical world and please check
out my video on antibiotic resistance
bacteria and that's it for today thanks
for watching biology professor